quando eu fui cortado para falar sobre o
poder do diálogo aqui no ted primeira
reflexão que me veio foi a relação entre
o diálogo e um exemplo já que o tema
principal seria o exemplo e eu
selecionei duas historinhas que talvez
sejam bem ilustrativas pra todos aqui
a primeira delas é se passou há muitos
anos eu tinha cerca de sete anos e
naquela época e na verdade até hoje o
meu exemplo de pessoal era o meu avô foi
uma figura fora de série era um médico
humanista cuidava do corpo e da alma das
pessoas
eu gostava tanto do meu avô que eu
queria trocar o meu nome de fernando
prass e bastião e um belo dia aos 78
anos de idade meu avô me sentou num
banco na varanda da casa dele e me pediu
apenas uma coisa e pediu que eu fosse
honesto com o passar dos anos eu percebi
que eu não escolhi a cidade que meu avô
tanto amava namorar
não escolhi a profissão do meu avô eu
não escolhi o time de futebol do meu avô
mas eu levei comigo
o princípio que norteia toda a minha
vida
o diálogo naquele momento apesar de meu
avô de ser
de ter sido sempre o exemplo da minha
vida
o diálogo complementou deu a roupagem
final que precisa que eu precisava para
tornar aquele exemplo como uma coisa
concreta na minha vida
em outra oportunidade muito mais tarde
já com o professor da universidade
um colega meu da ordem dos advogados do
brasil comentou que toda vez que um
curso de direito internacional era
lançado
os primeiros alunos a se matricularem
eram os meus alunos que os mais
interessados no curso eram os meus
alunos
fiquei muito satisfeito obviamente mas
passei a refletir se naquele momento eu
já seria por acaso o exemplo para os
meus alunos de alguma maneira e percebi
também naquele momento que ora nenhuma
eu tinha tentado transmitir por meio do
diálogo
aquele princípio que pra mim era o mais
relevante a questão da honestidade e
passei a partir daquele momento a
compartilhar dialogar com os alunos a
questão da honestidade mas nós estamos
aqui para falar sobre o diálogo e eu
quero aprofundar um pouquinho nesse tema
ea pergunta que ia se apesar de tanto a
comunicação e ninguém tem dúvida que
estamos nos comunicando muito pelas
redes sociais e mesmo pessoalmente
apesar da comunicação se nós realmente
estamos nos entendendo e quem vai
começar a responder isso pra gente
esse caracter chinês que tem ali quatro
figuras uma delas representando ouvido
a outra
os olhos porque o contato visual é muito
importante uma conversa a pessoa
realmente percebe que você está dando
atenção nela na medida em que você não
perde o contato visual
toda sua atenção que não é apenas o
olhar mas toda a maneira de se portar
maneira de virar pessoa maneira de
recebê la e também todo o coração que é
um conjunto dessa obra mas também o
interesse que você vai colocar na
conversa para extrair da pessoa aquilo
que ela realmente quer passar essa o que
esse carácter chinesa ele representa o
que a gente chama na mediação que
trabalha sobretudo com o diálogo
a escuta ativa é uma das técnicas que
nós utilizamos hoje na verdade chamado
por alguns autores de observação ativa
já que trabalha com uma noção muito mais
completa do que seja ouvir e o primeiro
passo para quem quer estabelecer um
diálogo com qualquer outra pessoa é
entender a partir do ouvido a partir de
todo o coração a partir da atenção
dispensada ea partir do contato visual é
lógico nós não estamos imunes aqui há
problemas nós é uma sociedade né na vida
pessoal e na vida profissional pode
encontrar os problemas a todo momento e
isso não é novidade pra ninguém
certamente o que talvez seja novidade
para alguns isso foi novidade para mim
alguns anos atrás quando eu passei a
trabalhar com mediação é que o problema
o conflito ele pode e deve ser encarado
com um momento ideal para transformação
como algo positivo na vida é no momento
que surgiu o conflito você tem uma
oportunidade de identificar novos
caminhos têm a oportunidade de balançar
algumas certezas que a gente tem
esses caminhos novos que a gente
encontra a partir do diálogo
eles surgem na medida em que você
observa ativamente o outro em que você
aceita o diálogo para ouvir e entender o
que a outra pasta dizendo que a partir
desse momento quando você entende a
outra parte sabe quais são os motivos os
fundamentos pelos quais ele está
adotando essa ou aquela postura aí sim
você passa a gerar opções assim você
passa a se colocar no lugar do outro e
aí sim você passa a entender o mundo
todo o próprio que não era seu
você passa a se incluir naquele mundo e
ter a oportunidade de se transformar a
oportunidade de vencer aquela
perspectiva inicial de nascimento que
ela projeção genética
você passa a perceber outras nuances que
você não tinha até aquele momento o
diálogo balança nossas certezas em
várias circunstâncias nas sessões de
mediação que nós fazemos e às vezes o
erro do próprio mediador que faz uma
pergunta muito fechada e eu já me vi
nessa circunstância em algumas situações
eu perguntei você acha que seu pai deve
dar o exemplo ou seu pai deve
simplesmente negar o direito à sua irmã
e para minha surpresa a resposta foi
deve simplesmente negar que naquele
momento gente e todos os alunos sempre
me pergunta isso e se vêem nessas
situações o que fazer
conhecer e aprofundar o conhecimento no
mundo do outro
qual foi a razão para aquela resposta
ela me respondeu porque a minha irmã não
tem maturidade suficiente para entender
que era o concorde quer não o tenho aí
pelo menos diversas respostas a serem
possíveis eu posso conversar pra negar
eu posso dar um exemplo negar posso
negar e dar o exemplo posso simplesmente
negar mas o que é fundamental em
entender como o outro vê o mundo ea
partir dessa perspectiva poder ajudava a
criar opções para que a gente possa se
entender por que a gente possa se
comunicar
quando a gente pára sozinho aí começa a
refletir sobre determinadas
circunstâncias na nossa vida
a gente vai só obtendo cada vez mais
fundamento cada vez mais argumento para
se posicionar daquela maneira e na
interação e no diálogo é na escuta que a
gente cura a alma como a gente gosta de
falar esse nosso amigo aqui têm essa
frase fantástica dizer que a cura agora
vai entrar pelo ouvido a cura da alma
pela palavra não é mais uma cura pelo
remédio
pelo menos em boa medida eu acredito
nisso mas a imagem mais interessante
exatamente desse filme tarja branca
o filme trata sobre a arte de brincar
pode parecer um pouco estranho né
mas acho que todos aqui tem uma cabeça
muito avançada e consegue compreender
que isso tem uma profundidade extrema
sobre a arte de brincar revolução das
crianças a revolução que faltava em uma
passagem desse filme
uma senhora entrevistada disse que
estava caminhando
na praça da sociedade e se deparou com
duas crianças soltando pipa papagaio e
naquele momento uma comentou com a outra
batida batiza batiza e ela um pouco sem
saber do que se tratava
parou pra assistir a brincadeira das
crianças e saber o que significava
batizar e percebeu que batizar
significava utilizar toda linha do
papagaio em toda a linha da pipa quando
você consegue esticar toda a linha
você precisou e ela saiu dali refletindo
sobre o que significaria brincar e
chegou uma belíssima conclusão que
brincar é esticar todo filho de vida
brincar é utilizar toda a sua
potencialidade todo seu gingado toda a
sua inteligência todo seu potencial
mas por outro lado ela me colocou numa
situação extremamente difícil
foi a partir dali eu falei se usará todo
o fio de vida é brincar o que sobrou
para dialogar e comecei a refletir sobre
aquilo
cheguei a uma conclusão se brincar é
utilizar todo o fio de vida dialogar e
encontrar outros filhos divina fios de
variada cor textura tamanho
com os quais devemos conviver
calma
isso me levou uma outra reflexão
acho que todos aqui se impressionam com
os projetos sociais que nós vamos ter
que uma palavra sobre o projeto social
daqui a pouco mas o que me impressionava
é que na grande maioria que eu conheço
tem um sucesso esplendoroso muitos deles
de arte de dança música com palhaçaria
de xadrez matemática futebol
todos eles têm um gera uma alegria para
as pessoas resultado as pessoas sim
poderão isso me levou a refletir
reflexão qual seria o ponto em comum em
todos esses projetos ea minha conclusão
foi que em todos esses projetos existe o
diálogo em todos esses projetos existe o
acolhimento o entendimento do mundo do
outro e foi no nesse ambiente de
reflexão e quando voltei pra juiz de
fora recentemente juntamente com os
alunos e os professores da universidade
que ninguém faz nada sozinho
criamos um núcleo de mediação
extrajudicial projeto dialogar que tem
por objetivo restabelecer o laço social
entre as pessoas não resolve todos os
problemas infelizmente até gostaria mas
não resolve todos os problemas ele
indicado para um determinado tipo de
problema é uma opção vamos dizer assim
em relação ao judiciário que tem certos
problemas que só são
passíveis de serem solucionados pelo
judiciário mas é uma outra porta para a
solução de determinados problemas
sobretudo problemas vinculados a
relacionamentos de longo prazo
leia se basicamente relacionamentos
familiares e de vizinhança é o nosso
grande público
nós trabalhamos basicamente com a idéia
do empoderamento das pessoas para que
elas ganhem autonomia e solucionem os
próprios problemas
quem resolve o problema resolve os
nossos problemas somos nós mesmos
vocês terem uma idéia o ano passado aqui
em minas gerais foi proposta uma ação em
que os pais discutiam qual escola a
criança deveria ser matriculada
obviamente com a propositura da ação o
que eles estavam fazendo era entregar o
problema para que o juiz decidisse que
exatamente tudo o que nós não queremos
nós queremos que as pessoas sejam
autônomas para resolver e solucionar os
seus próprios problemas
a partir do empoderamento ela se tornou
autônomas e podem discutir em pé de
igualdade com as outras pessoas dentro
desse projeto
existe também um projeto de implantação
de novos centros de mediação
já criamos uma câmara municipal a que
devia de fora e estamos com três
projetos em andamentos nos bairros da
periferia
nós entendemos que a mediação
comunitária pode ser um grande avanço
para para as comunidades para a cidade
como um todo
no núcleo de mediação do projeto alongar
eu costumo dizer que a mediação é
revolucionária
convido todos vocês a dialogar muito
obrigado
ae